if I saw these I would donate them I
wouldn't even wear them today we're
going to guess the price of ripped jeans
do you wear rip t absolutely not I have
one pair of jeans although I did have
ripped jeans when I was playing music
and I had little money I know that
people always have that misconception
like why pay more for less I personally
like them it's just a more casual vibe
for myself because they're cute and they
have a rip I'm going to get that okay
make sense let's see if I can get close
to the right price
these ones are like very big holes this
is hideous
no offence not very practical for formal
occasions but they smell like you're
going out in the day to like a job
interview in their jeans your entire
thigh I mean seriously what if there is
a theme in like it's a cowboy thing but
you want to be the cute cowboy if you'd
wear these oh it was like a plaid shirt
I think it's gonna be one of those crazy
prices like 200 bucks yeah 175 I hope
they were like 40 I'm gonna defer to you
since you are the RIP team lady okay $60
[Music]
okay we know who knows the stuff better
than I do
second pair these kind of wrinkly and oh
these ones have skin tags on them what
with the stick nevermind they got five
four buttons no five either like Levi's
cute little buttons here I feel like
it's a different type of denim than the
last one take it more expensive nothing
that I would wear certainly not sober
buttons make it more 200 bucks 150 95
I'm gonna say 60 bucks
okay good
so is this like intentional like Pete
and they painted it for you and it's
Rocco brand I've never I've never heard
of heard that brand of this song before
it belonged to a painter these are
definitely used I feel like I see true
origin at t.j.maxx that's where I shop I
feel that these rips are less
intentional I would probably say like 75
65 I'm gonna stick to 150 that's my safe
space I feel like it's just 50 oh you
got that I can give mine coffee stains
for free okay so lies don't want my
house a French name that adds a hundred
bucks super stained super hole if you
put these on in a hurry your foot will
come out here really distressed they
have little guitar pick pocket see okay
200 bucks 200 bet yeah yeah I'm gonna
agree 125 I'm gonna go to 175 I don't
understand why they're 270 like we can
do this at home this looks like a DIY
project
they're very stretchy they're kind of
like just jeggings we needed ripped
jeans for a formal occasion these will
be the ones these are you banging look
at that these remind me of pins that
they saw at Costco 25 no 45
three washes they'll be done yeah like
1789 okay no but isn't yeah you're
pretty close good getting better at this
are they like 50% off that's not worth
it to Washington they're done Jay a
brand so we know I don't know
it's expensive oh okay that's the
section I go through yeah I go hmm wish
yes they're slightly rich you're not
ripped enough to cost too much that's
true
these are actually kind of tastefully
done yeah I like behavioral I would wear
these ripped in places that make it easy
to access I'm gonna see 200 bucks yeah
I'm gonna trust you 200 200 1695 2195
okay not a smart person two jeans okay
another path again they're laughing
jeans they're very stretching me look at
that yeah it just kind of looks like
string cheese I'm gonna say 171 stretch
at the ankles that's a plug I guess
that's so nice what did you say 175 okay
I'm gonna go with that we know fashion
Nova is overpriced so we're gonna have
to guess 45 better than the other ones
more holes for your money okay okay good
these are so soft Uniqlo oh yeah I like
that yeah you know have like rocks it
looks like I had patches at one time fee
this isn't a real rip if there's more
denim underneath the bed then it's not a
bit it's just like it's modern let's
just say modest rip I think probably 30
95 I'm gonna go 60 bucks 40 bucks
cuz Uniqlo is 40 before you might even
be high yeah hey if you want ripped
jeans wear them I don't care
have at it knock yourself out all about
the brand put a French name on it in
fact maybe leather bag let her rip
[Music]
[Music]